Let's say we have an endpoint at
/puppies that returns a collection of
puppies with their date of birth
in the format of month, date, and
year, like so.
Later on, we realize that we can
also include the information of
the time of birth for each puppy.
But we must change the format
of the date of birth like so.
How do we add this feature
without causing problems for
users already using our endpoint?
Versioning allows you to make
new functionalities without
breaking features for
users still using older implementations.
If your application renders webpages and
has API endpoints, specifying the API
in your URIs is also helpful for users.
Another method of implementing
versioning is by including the version
number in your HTTP header.
GitHub implements versioning this way.
Whichever method you choose, versioning
is an important consideration for
your users as your application grows and
changes.